quand est la parole est à Madame A
poursu poli pour la motion et pour deux
minutes
comme vous voulez ma chère collègues
vous avez deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente nous y sommes
au cœur de votre projet de loi déclaré
irrecevable par notre peuple la
mobilisation est massive la levée
populaire rappelle les grandes heures de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
monsieur le ministre il vous reste la
légalité institutionnelle mais vous avez
perdu la légitimité sociale nous ne
pourrons plus poursuivre le débat de la
même manière qu'hier votre texte est
massivement rejeté nous le savions tous
depuis le 19 janvier date de la première
journée de manifestation et de grève nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens n'ont pas
lâché ils sont aujourd'hui plus nombreux
encore dans l'action c'est un
raz-de-marée contre la réforme
profondément injuste de Monsieur Macron
et de son gouvernement nous l'avons dit
répéter comment avez-vous osé provoquer
le pays ainsi s'il y a blocage si nous
sommes dans cette situation de crise
sociale majeure monsieur le ministre aux
côtés
le contrôle du président de la
République et de la première ministre
vous emportez l'unique responsabilité
votre obsession libérale votre pensée
dogmatique vous ont poussé à la faute
vous êtes tombé dans votre propre piège
dont vous aurez bien du mal à vous
sortir vous n'avez plus expliqué au
travailleur qu'il soit salarié ou non
pourquoi ils devront s'user à la tâche
plus longtemps portez l'âge légal du
départ à la retraite à 64 ans n'a pu
passer car tous ont bien compris que
d'autres moyens existent pour financer
le régime des retraites par répartition
d'autres solutions dont vous n'avez pas
parlé à commencer par mettre à
contribution les richesses considérables
de la grande puissance que nous sommes
main dans la main le président de la
République et la majorité sénatoriale
dans l'affichage enfin de cette union
des droites veulent imposer la
destruction d'un pilier de notre
République la sécurité sociale écoutons
le peuple écoutons pour une fois le
peuple soutenez mes chers collègues
notre demande refuser l'âge de départ à
64 ans merci chers collègues
alors quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente mais
c'est strictement interdit jour appelle
mes collègues un peu de respect quand
même pour l'assistance s'il vous plaît
vous voulez peut-être toujours fait moi
je vous dis c'est interdit madame la
Présidente assassin j'en suis désolé
voilà la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur non n'est pas la parole même
la présidente pour l'instant non même la
Présidente je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur
je suis en cours de parole
monsieur le rapporteur merci Madame
Liliane
est en passé on va revenir à la sérénité
des débats
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes serein nous aussi parce que
nous pensons que véritablement si nous
proposons une réforme dont on sait
qu'elle peut être difficile à accepter
pour certains
c'est pour faire que nous puissions
maintenir notre système de répartition à
l'équilibre et quand on sait que nous
avons de moins en moins de cotisants et
des retraites qui durent de plus en plus
longtemps si nous prenons pas nos
responsabilités ce sont les générations
futures qui paieront la note et qui la
paieront beaucoup plus cher il nous
appartient et vous le savez
de poursuivre le débat nos concitoyens
l'attendent ce débat en ce qui concerne
effectivement ces inégalités ces
inégalités qu'il y a dans la vie
professionnelle ces inégalités qui se
déclinent également dans le système de
retraite et nos concitoyens sont
impatients ils nous l'ont dit que leur
en propose que leur propose
qu'on leur propose des mesures qui
prennent en compte ces inégalités
qui prennent en compte l'usure
professionnelle qui prennent en compte
les maires de famille ça fait déjà
plus de 3 jours que nous siègeons où
nous avons entendu nombre de discours
tout à fait justifié et il nous
appartient maintenant de passer à l'acte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
donnons un avis défavorable pour
retourner en commission faire le travail
que nous avons déjà largement fait merci
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
la discussion sur la première partie a
montré que le sujet s'il est complexe
est aussi un sujet qui peut être clivant
et qui a l'occasion de cette discussion
en première partie sur les différents
articles financiers sur les déclarations
générales ces questions relatives à
l'âge au choix que nous avons fait
évidemment et il faut le dire des
demandez un effort aux Français avec un
peu plus de travail faire
progressivement certes certes de manière
plus aussi adaptée possible et aussi
justement réparti que possible peut
faire débat ce que nous avons fait nous
l'avons fait pour deux raisons parce que
c'est celui qui permet d'une part de
ramener le système à l'équilibre et
d'autre part de financer à la fois les
mesures d'accompagnement et les droits
nouveaux que nous créons avec cette
réforme je crois qu'il les travaux en
commission les travaux à l'occasion de
la première partie ont déjà largement
éclairé le débat qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
retarder ce débat sur l'article 7 donc
la vie est défavorable
si beaucoup alors y a-t-il des
explications de vote un représentant par
groupe même
merci madame la Présidente cet article
est effectivement au cœur de la réforme
la mobilisation considérable à laquelle
nous assistons aujourd'hui la grève
puissante qui a été lancée dans le
secteur public comme dans le secteur
privé à un objectif clair et précis le
retrait de ce projet détestable qui
institut le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite mais aussi de tout
l'habillage l'accompagnant relevant bien
souvent de la manipulation même du
mensonge comme ce plancher à 2000 à 1200
euros pardon destiné d'abord à
l'ensemble des retraités à venir et
actuels pour finalement être réservé à
10000 au mieux 20 000 personnes cette
mobilisation marque aussi un ras-le-bol
bien plus profond une colère rentrée
cette colère elle s'exprime comme contre
cette société injuste marquée par la
précarité précarité dans le travail le
logement l'accès aux soins le
déroulement des études l'accès aux
services publics nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens n'en plus de toutes ces
inégalités qui s'accroisent dans notre
pays avec un étalage indécent de
richesse un affichage de profits
dantesques accumulé y compris sur le dos
des crises sanitaires énergie
énergétique sur la sur la guerre c'est
profiteurs de crise les maîtres de la
finance ceux qui tiennent l'actionnariat
ont poussé à une telle réforme ce sont
eux qui ont tenu la main de Monsieur
Macron pour écrire ce nouvel
asservissement que décrète ce projet de
loi les femmes et les hommes de ce pays
le voient le savent elle et il le cri
ils ont soif de justice d'égalité la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat comme le Parlement tout entier
doit travailler dans la précipitation
extrême décidée par le seul gouvernement
la voie choisie de l'article 7 1 permet
d'aller vite mais ça n'est pas
démocratique ce n'est pas le bon vecteur
législatif il est temps maintenant
madame la Présidente de nous réunir à
nouveau pour prendre en compte ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui une très grande
colère et un rejet massif de cette
réforme scélérate merci même la
présidente rossignol
merci Madame la président
merci madame la Présidente il y a un
instant le rapporteur nous disait ça
fait trois jours que nous siégeons nous
pouvons donc continuer il n'y a pas de
raison de retourner en commission ça
fait trois jours que nous sions et que
nous parlons de gens qui travaillent
depuis plus de 40 ans qui eux attendent
la retraite qui prennent le train tous
les matins c'est se demander partement
pour beaucoup d'entre eux qui tous les
jours compte parce que vous n'y pensez
pas vous n'y pensez pas aux gens qui ont
un calendrier et qui cochent les jours
parce que après une vie de travail après
une vie de souffrance après une vie de
fatigue on les attendent la retraite
parce que c'est le moment ils pourront
enfin s'occuper de leurs petits-enfants
avoir des loisirs et puis surtout se
reposer alors franchement entre des gens
qui travaillent depuis plus de 40 ans et
qui attendent la retraite et nous qui
travaillons depuis trois jours retourner
en commission on a le temps on peut le
faire et puis et par ailleurs
retournez en commission pourquoi faire
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser en
bon membre de la commission des affaires
sociales que nous sommes les uns et les
autres mais je vous proposais déjà un
ordre du jour pour le retour en
commission recevoir l'Inter syndicale
nous ne l'avons jamais fait en
commission en tant que telle
et puis peut-être que ça donnera des
idées au gouvernement et aux ministres
et à la première ministre qui pourront
eux aussi pendant que nous serons en
commission à rediscuter de cet article 7
recevoir l'intersyndical ils ne l'ont
jamais reçus
alors je vous suggère effectivement de
faire comme mon groupe de voter cette
motion en commission pour examiner
article 7
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Gontard
oui merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente de la même manière évidemment
que nous soutiendrons ce renvoi en
commission d'abord quand même une
remarque parce que c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on met des visages
derrière cette réforme à chaque fois
qu'on parle des gens à chaque fois qu'on
met des prénoms à chaque fois qu'on cite
des professions ça vous gêne on entend
et je pense que c'est c'est
particulièrement oui mais ça pose quand
même question parce que c'est quand même
ce qu'on est en train de faire on est en
train de changer de la vie de gens
justement derrière leur prénom derrière
le métier et de leur dire que vous allez
travailler un an deux ans de plus c'est
une réalité et un moment va falloir
aussi l'assumer parce que c'est pas que
des chiffres c'est pas que des textes
derrière il y a des personnes donc ça je
pense que c'est aussi important que vous
l'ayez en tête ensuite se renvoie en
commission et le fait peut-être d'avoir
un peu plus de temps pour que
effectivement je vois que le ministre
ont besoin de discuter ont besoin de
parler donc je pense qu'on a peut-être
besoin de se renvoi en commission merci
Monsieur le merci monsieur le ministre
et puis
également j'ai lu j'ai entendu un peu
près j'ai vu dans certains articles en
tout cas il y a des bruits qui courent
qui auraient des réunions en tout cas
qu'on commencerait à discuter de la
future de la future CMP qu'on sera en
train de se mettre d'accord parce que
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur n'est
plus le rapporteur de la commission
parce que il dit nous il est le
rapporteur du groupe du groupe LR il est
le rapporteur de ce texte et le
rapporteur du gouvernement donc très
bien je veux dire vous êtes en train de
faire un texte entre vous c'est très
bien donc je pense qu'il y a peut-être
ce temps là mais nous on a peut-être
aussi du temps pour avancer pour vous
faire des propositions on a essayé d'en
faire depuis trois jours je pense qu'on
va encore en faire et on a encore du
temps devant nous et on va pas se priver
de vous faire des propositions parce que
effectivement ce texte est
particulièrement injuste et je pense que
les manifestations ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui sans précédent dans notre
pays un moment il va falloir peut-être
l'entendre parce que non on ne gouverne
pas contre le peuple
merci Monsieur mouillé
merci Madame présidente mes chers
collègues nous comprenons tout à fait
que nous sommes là à la veille quelques
minutes de l'examen de l'article 7 et
que vu la situation de la journée vous
soyez motivé remonté pour porter vos
valeurs et donc votre vision on le
comprend tout à fait mais toutefois
comme ça a été très bien dit par
rapporteur rappelons que nous sommes
cohérents dans nos démarches et que le
début de l'examen de ce texte nous
savons que la technique 7 et l'article
fondamentale pour équilibrer notre futur
système de retraite à l'aube de 2030
c'était essentiel nous le savons et vous
vous devez évoquer souvent des visages
des rencontres des personnes souffrantes
que vous rencontrez mais nous également
lorsqu'on rencontre un certain nombre de
couple et que en évoque avec eux
l'avenir de leur retraite souvent nous
disent on n'aura pas de retraite les
plus jeunes j'ai dit on n'aura pas de
retraite non pas parce que vous évoquez
vos arrivants c'est parce qu'ils savent
pertinemment que si on met pas en place
une réforme courageuse avec des vraies
valeurs nous serons incapables de
financer un niveau digne de retraite et
donc c'est l'outil que nous proposons
aujourd'hui
donc on a aussi ce regard vis-à-vis de
nos concitoyens et puis pour ceux qui
évoquent le fait de d'avoir plus de
temps en commission l'interse à
desquelles a été reçu en commission il
fallait peut-être présent que les choses
à ce moment-là et puis depuis 4 ans nous
avons le même discours nous travaillons
nous avons reçu un satombe d'acteurs
dans cette mission donc il y a rien de
nouveau nous sommes nous sommes prêts
les sales ont été rencontrés ont été vu
simplement un moment donné relisez les
contrôles de commission et on gagne du
temps ce soir merci
même
la parole pour rappeler en effet que le
15 février nous avons passé la matinée à
recevoir les organisations syndicales
les organisations patronales et que les
rapporteurs les queues je ne sais pas si
vous êtes intervenus lors de cette
commission madame madame Rossignol on
regardera je n'en ai pas vraiment le
souvenir mais pourquoi pas oui pourquoi
pas mais enfin ça c'est un détail les
rapporteurs depuis
des années que nous faisons des
amendements pfss reçoivent les
organisations syndicales certes ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec la proposition
qu'on fait mais néanmoins nous les
recevons et puis moi je vais vous dire
j'en ai un peu marre de ces propos ici
disons mais qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez du travail qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez de la vie qu'est-ce que vous
savez vous de nos origines qu'est-ce que
vous savez de nos vies
rien
donc j'en ai un petit peu marre
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos vies
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos familles
qu'est-ce que vous savez ce qu'on a vécu
ou ce que nos parents ont vécu rien
alors vous arrêtez avec ça
merci
alors je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
motion de renvoi à la commission de 7 la
vie du gouvernement et de la commission
sont défavorables qui est pour
cette motion qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté
alors à l'article 7 j'ai des demandes de
prise de parole et le premier monsieur
le rapporteur Savary
oui merci madame la Présidente nous y
voilà nous y voilà
c'est le Ministre ça fait quatre ans
qu'on vous propose ce type
d'acheitecture de réforme c'est pas
parce que nous sommes des tétus c'est
parce que nous pensons que c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire en sorte de
pouvoir équilibrer notre système de
retraite si nous voulons le confier à
nos enfants et effectivement on sait que
nous avons un système fondé sur deux
piliers à la fois la durée de cotisation
et un autre pilier un âge légal la durée
de cotisation qui a été ramenée de 41
ans et demi à 43 ans par un gouvernement
que vous avez largement soutenu et on
vous en remercie parce que c'est tout à
fait important mais on sait que cette
durée de cotisation quand on augmente
elle concerne davantage ceux qui
commencent tôt mais elle a un défaut
c'est que le niveau de pension moyenne
va diminuer derrière
c'est l'équation qui est ainsi faite
dans le calcul des pensions de carrière
et puis il y a un deuxième vecteur c'est
l'âge légal on sait que l'âge légal
touche plus spécifiquement et fait pour
ça pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
protéger ceux qui commencent à
travailler tard et il a l'avantage c'est
d'augmenter le niveau des pensions et
nous avons pensé déjà depuis quatre ans
qu'il était important de trouver un
équilibre entre les deux de façon à ce
que quand on demande un effort collectif
à l'ensemble des Français il y ait le
moins d'inégalité possible c'est la
raison pour laquelle ces inégalités nous
souhaitons les gommer
parce que elles sont réelles et en
conséquence monsieur le ministre si vous
nous avez rejoint dans la démarche
vous n'avez pas été tout à fait jusqu'au
bout il reste encore un bout de chemin à
faire parce que si nous avions présenté
nous cette réforme nous l'aurions pas
fait de cette façon nous aurions déjà
consulté
nous aurions déjà consulter les sociaux
avant et nous aurions pris en compte les
difficultés rencontrées dans le cadre de
cet effort collectif c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons débattre et
que je ne suis pas sûr que 57
amendements de suppression tout ce
identique face correctement avancé le
débat merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors pour les
prises de parole madame la Présidente
Éliane assassy oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lors de la présentation du projet de loi
la première ministre a placé son projet
sous le signe de je cite la préservation
d'un système menacé menacé par
l'accumulation des déficits qui seraient
irresponsable ce sont ces mots le
gouvernement justifie l'allongement de
l'âge légal à 64 ans et de la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités par le déficit
de système de retraite pour 2030 à 13,5
je rappelle quand même qu'en 2019 lors
de la précédente réforme le gouvernement
invoquait déjà l'impérius nécessité de
réformer le système de retraite face au
risque d'un déficit du régime de 10
milliards d'euros en 2022 la réforme fut
abandonnée sans réforme le système de
retraite a été excédentaire de 3,7
milliards d'euros alors on peut
s'interroger sur votre entêtement
monsieur le ministre de bien de vouloir
imposer deux années de travail
supplémentaire à nos concitoyens et si
je ne connais pas la vie de chaque
parlementaire ici présent je connais
celle de centaines de s'écano Dionysiens
parmi lesquels celles et ceux que nous
avons applaudis pendant l'épidé
l'épidémie et qui refuse aujourd'hui
qu'on leur vole deux années de leur vie
les 8 syndicats de salariés sont unis
dans l'intercyndicale
ils ont organisé cinq journées de
mobilisation qui ont rassemblé
énormément de monde je rappelle que le
19 janvier il y avait manifeste en le 31
janvier 2,8 le 7 2 millions le 11 2,5
millions le 16 1,3 millions et c'était
pendant les vacances scolaires
aujourd'hui et nous y est on présente je
me félicite d'un mouvement social
d'ampleur et rassembleur ce sont plus de
3,5 millions de manifestants parmi
lesquels des milliers de jeunes qui ont
défilé aujourd'hui autour d'un mot
d'ordre retrait de votre réforme
monsieur le ministre votre obstination
met en danger notre société et vous vous
obstinez avec la complicité de la
majorité sénatoriale alors je vous le
dis sincèrement retirer ce projet de loi
pendant qu'il est encore temps merci
même Cathy pour ce poli
merci madame la
Présidente excusez-moi Xavier Bertrand
demandait je cite à la fin de cette
décennie il faudra que l'on arrive à
deux années de travail en plus en
excluant ceux qui ont son usé par le
boulot pour Valérie Pécresse je cite
reculer à 65 ans avec des contreparties
pour les longs les carrières longues et
sur la pénibilité Michel Barnier
défendait quant à lui une pension
minimale à 1000 euros philippe Juvin
était le seul candidat qui demandait la
mise en oeuvre d'une capitalisation
collective complémentaire en décembre
2022 pour l'élection du président du
parti des républicains notre collègue le
candidat Bruno Retailleau défendait la
fermeture des régimes spéciaux
l'allongement à 64 ans et 43 annuités
comme le gouvernement
tandis que le député Aurélien Pradier
s'opposé à l'âge à l'allongement de
l'âge légal le candidat élu depuis
président des républicains érectionti
défendait lui le report en 2027 l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 65 ans
et à 63 ans pour les carrières longues
cette réforme des retraites ne
correspond donc ni au projet d'Aurélien
Pradier ni d'érections ni de Xavier
Bertrand ni de Philippe Juvin mais
uniquement à celle portée par le
président du groupe les républicains
monsieur Retailleau
alors alors chers collègues en attendant
que vous vous mettez d'accord évidemment
pas ici parce qu'ici c'est quand même un
pour tous pour un et bien je vous
propose de retirer votre projet de
retraite néfaste pour les Français et
les Françaises je vous remercie merci
même Laurence Cohen vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente le
gouvernement justifie le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite comme une
réforme de justice et de progrès ce même
gouvernement se félicite d'acter l'âge
de 64 ans au lieu de 65 ans comme s'il
travaillait deux années de plus de
représentait rien non seulement la
potion est amère mais elle est indigeste
monsieur le ministre les femmes vont
souffrir de cette réforme et le report
de l'âge légal défendu par se présente
article aura de lourds conséquences sur
elle et leur quotidien même si c'est
l'ensemble des Français qui vont
souffrir les femmes subissent déjà de
nombreuses inégalités lors de la
recherche d'emploi sur les salaires sur
les conséquences des crises sur leur
représentation dans les métiers pénibles
et non valorisés la réforme ne réduira
pas ses inégalités au contraire elle les
creusera à chaque fois qu'on repousse la
durée de cotisation on la rend toujours
moins atteignable pour les femmes si les
salaires des femmes sont inférieurs en
moyenne de 22% de ceux des hommes leur
pension de droit est inférieure de 40% à
celle des hommes alors s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre assumez vos
positions arrêtez ces mensonges qui
laissent sous entendre que cette réforme
est favorable aux femmes elle subissent
depuis des décennies des réformes
injustes et cette réforme ajoute une
pièce à la machine et confirme le modèle
de société antisociale que vous défendez
si vous voulez renflouer les caisses
faites respecter la loi en matière
d'égalité salariale on voulait déjà on
vous l'a déjà dit 6 milliards
supplémentaires de cotisations sociales
non seulement cette égalité dans la vie
active permettrait mécaniquement
d'augmenter le niveau de pension des
femmes mais en plus cela permettrait de
revaloriser de façon bien plus
importante que ce que vous faites les
prestations sociales et les retraites
alors ne cherchez pas de faux arguments
de faux prétextes pour justifier cette
réforme retirez-la écoutez la voix de la
rue
merci la parole est à Monsieur Thierry
Cosic
l'un de nos illustre prédécesseur le
président Mitterrand nous avait prévenu
après moi
il n'y aura que des comptables
et à l'examen de cet article monsieur le
ministre comment lui donner tort cet
article 7 vient toucher au coeur le
projet que vous portez et il ne trahit
que trop bien l'idéologie qui vous anime
en la matière
tout d'abord permettez-moi de vous dire
que cet article me paraît quasi
anachronique tant il fait fi des
bouleversements qui traversent notre
société depuis quelques années et
auxquels le gouvernement semble fermer
et pourtant la forte mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui en témoigne nous vivons
une période de changement sociétaux
gigantesque avec un nouveau rapport au
travail qui est en mutation une
déstabilisation liée à la crise
sanitaire qui laisse encore des traces
aujourd'hui
l'ignorer c'est aller dans le mur
pour schématiser il y a trois grands
paramètres sur lesquels jouer pour
réformer notre système de retraite l'âge
de départ la durée et le niveau de
cotisation
des trois il n'y en a qu'un seul qui
touche les salariés de manière inégale
c'est la mesure d'âge car vous le savez
elle ne prend pas en considération la
date d'entrée sur le marché du travail
de fait en repoussant comme vous le
faites là je les gale vous envoyez une
facture
différente à nos concitoyens selon le
moment auquel ils auront commencé à
travailler et une fois n'est pas coutume
la facture la plus lourde
elle est pour ceux qu'on a appelé les
travailleurs de la deuxième ligne
pendant la pandémie les hôtes et
hôtesses de caisses les éboueurs les
agents d'entretien ou les aides à
domicile qui sont aussi les grands
perdants de la mondialisation et de la
numérisation de l'économie voilà comment
vous remercier Monsieur le Ministre
toute cette frange de salariés dont on a
mesuré l'importance pendant les crises
sanitaires et qui ont commencé à
travailler jeune et on les mettait les
plus les plus pénibles merci
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues monsieur le ministre est-ce
que cette fois vous l'avez entendu la
riposte populaire cette mobilisation de
millions de Françaises et de français
partout dans le pays qui vous en dit que
de cette réforme in en voulait pas et
mes amis de DLR faites très attention
parce que parmi les manifestants il y a
sûrement une partie de votre électorat
il n'en veulent pas parce qu'elle est
injuste à travers le report de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans vous faites supporter la
totalité des efforts sur les seuls
travailleurs les classes moyennes les
plus vulnérables ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt qui ont exercé des
métiers difficiles ceux qui ont du mal à
se maintenir en emploi après 58 ans les
femmes les personnes précaires au
chômage en maladie au RSA alors
qu'aucune aucune contribution n’est
demandée aux employeurs aux revenus aux
actionnaires non monsieur le ministre
votre réforme n'est pas de gauche elle
va à l'encontre de nos valeurs de notre
récit collectif souvenez-vous
souvenez-vous de ça vous avez présenté
un bilan comptable alors que nous je
vous parlais en d'un projet de société
et jusqu'ici nous débats ont été des
dialogues de sourds sauf que depuis
aujourd'hui les rapports de force sont
claire la colère des Français vous
oblige elle vous oblige à prendre une
ultime décision soit vous renoncez à
fracturer le pays à mettre les Français
dans la rue vous retirez votre réforme
ouvrez des négociations collectives avec
les partenaires sociaux soit vous vous
obstinez à vouloir passer en force et je
crains qu'à ce moment là vous devriez
avoir au pire désormais le président de
la République ne peut plus se défiler il
faut qu'il parle aux Français qui ne les
poussent plus à bout qu'il les respecte
et qu'en frein enfin vous et lui vous
preniez acte du rejet de cette réforme
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pierre Laurent
la question qui nous occupe à cette
heure est une question
démocratique majeure après l'échec de
cette réforme à l'Assemblée nationale
une majorité du Sénat va-t-elle décider
de permettre le coup de force qui a été
qui est tenté par le gouvernement contre
les deux plus belles années de rotin des
Français un coup de force contre
l'immense majorité du pays un coup de
force contre tous les syndicats un coup
de force contre l'avenir du régime de
retraite par répartition nous débattons
ici depuis le 2 mars ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par Madame la rapporteur depuis
6 jours les Français nous écoutent les
Français nous suivent ils ont entendu
tous les arguments les vôtres les nôtres
ceux du rapporteur ceux du gouvernement
ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui en
connaissance de cause
et le pays a répondu clairement que pour
lui c'était non et il a dit non dans
toutes les villes de France dans tous
les départements dans toute nos régions
tous nos électeurs étaient dans la rue
quand je dis tous nos électeurs c'est
les nôtres c'est les vôtres aussi tous
étaient dans la rue pour dire NON de
toute catégories sociales et j'attire
votre attention parce que c'est un fait
majeur de la journée d'aujourd'hui
l'entrée en lice massif de la jeunesse
de la jeunesse dans les manifestations
et cela va s'amplifier
nous avons vérifié pendant cette
discussion ce que les syndicats ont
vérifié pendant trois mois en essayant
de négocier avec le gouvernement le
gouvernement et la droite ne veulent
rien négocier vous êtes obsédé par une
seule idée les 64 ans à part ça rien ne
vous intéresse aucune piste alternative
ne trouve grâce à vos yeux et bien je le
répète face au pays qui est unanimement
mobilisé c'est un coup de force ne
donnez pas la main à ce coup de force
sénateur et sénatrice du Sénat nous
n'avons pas à le faire
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
une minorité peut pas bloquer le pays
aujourd'hui vous êtes seul plus personne
ne croit en votre projet mise à part
peut-être encore la droite sénatoriale
donc je tiens à les féliciter pour leur
talent même sans parler vous avez réussi
à empirer le texte avec le contrat
dernier embauche ou en introduisant une
part de capitalisation aujourd'hui
massivement les travailleurs et
travailleuses vous ont répondu ils ont
déferlé dans toutes les rues à Paris
comme en province dans toutes les
sous-préfectures et les villages pour
vous dire non non ils ne veulent pas
qu'on leur vole les deux plus belles
années de leur vie à la retraite chez le
ministre
arrêté cette guerre sociale aux
travailleurs et travailleur essentiels
et utiles aux salariés du privé comme du
public au premier deuxième et troisième
ligne au commerce artisan professionnel
et le chef d'entreprise aux jeunes et
retraités tout le monde est uni pour
vous dire STOP il n'y a qu'une seule
option maintenant qui est sur la table
c'est celle du retrait de votre projet
de loi personne ne veut cela et en plus
tous vos arguments sont tombés un par un
parce que nous vous avons fait pendant 5
jours beaucoup de propositions
alternatives des propositions de
financement taxer le capital faire
l'égalité salariale mettre un million de
personnes en emploi ce sont des
ressources supplémentaires et vous les
refusez parce que vous n'avez comme la
dit Pierre Laurent qu'une seule
obsession faire payer au million de
travailleurs et travailleuses la crise
et donc les faire travailler chacune et
chacun deux ans pour tous et donc nous
nous continuerons à un pied à pied
déterminé utile pour faire échec à ce
projet jusqu'au retrait
merci la parole est à Monsieur Pascale
ça vole des lits
et non doucement quand même
merci Madame la présente messieurs les
Messieurs mes chers collègues
cette réforme sur le fond mais sur la
forme est en train d'exacerber la
défiance à l'autorité publique et à
l'autorité politique
déjà 54% des Français des Françaises
quel était leur vote pense que la
démocratie fonctionne pas bien et là on
va aller du transpartisan là
84% des Françaises et les Français
pensent que les citoyens doivent prendre
une part plus importante dans la
décision politique donc je vous le dis
messieurs les ministres
10 49,3 le 47 1 ne pas reprendre la vie
d'avoir un comportement de négation
vis-à-vis de la vie des syndicats d'une
majorité des Français je le dis mes
chers collègues on a des points de vue
différents mais la démocratie est à
l'épreuve aujourd'hui avec cette réforme
des retraites et ça c'est voulu et pour
nous les communistes la démocratie est
une valeur en soi et elle n'est pas
remplaçable et elle n'est pas
remplaçable et elle n'est pas remplacée
vous pouvez venir ce que vous voulez la
démocratie n'est pas remplaçable tout le
monde est légitime ici mais il faut
avoir l'humilité de sa représentativité
et ce que je veux dire aussi par là
c'est que comme c'est la démocratie est
dans l'idéal politique progressiste il
faut qu'on arrive et là j'appelle à
votre esprit de responsabilité messieurs
les ministres la démocratie sa vie par
le respect et le partage entre à la fois
un régime politique et nous sommes dans
le régime politique au Sénat nous sommes
à l'Assemblée nationale dans le régime
politique
constitution fait régime politique mais
il faut le faire avec respect partage
avec le mouvement social sinon la
démocratie va être plus que mise à
l'épreuve et on va vivre quelle semaine
quel mois et faire le lit de qui de qui
on va faire le lit du fascisme de
l'idéologie d'exclusion je vous le dis
ça a été fait un peu à l'Assemblée
nationale on a une lourde responsabilité
donc messieurs les ministres retirez
votre retraite et arrêter d'aller
chercher 300 milliards qu'il y a sur les
plans de retraite voilà ce que vous avez
fait avec la capitalisation
mais si la parole est à Madame Céline
Brulin
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
ça fait des semaines que vous argumentez
les uns et les autres pour dire tout le
bien que vous pensez de cette réforme et
bien malgré ça aujourd'hui le pays s'est
mobilisé encore plus massivement que les
autres jours
200000 manifestants en Normandie dans
une trentaine de rassemblements c'est du
jamais vu plus de 100000 rien que pour
la scène maritime alors vous dites oui
on comprend c'est un peu difficile de
travailler deux ans de plus mais
faites-le pour les générations futures
et bien précisément la particularité
d'aujourd'hui c'est que les générations
futures sont venues se joindre aux
actifs pour dire qu'il ne voulait pas de
cette réforme donc vous ne les avez pas
convaincu eux non plus
tout le monde vous le dit deux ans de
travail en plus c'est prendre leur deux
meilleures années de retraite ou
retraités c'est aussi les deux plus
dures années de travail que vous allez
leur infliger quand l'écorce sont usés
cassés pour tous les métiers que vous
avez applaudis mais que vous refusez de
reconnaître vos véritablement et à qui
vous mettez un coup de poignard dans le
dos aujourd'hui et puis il y a peut-être
quelque chose dont nous ne nous
saisissons pas assez
c'est la cohésion nationale de notre
pays qui peut être gravement impacté par
ce recul de l'âge de départ en retraite
parce que vous le savez tous qui anime
nous associations qui préside au
destinées de nos clubs sportifs qui va
chercher les gamins pour les conduire au
foot le dimanche qui s'impliquent dans
les conseils municipaux de nos communes
qui assurent la vitalité de cette vie
sociale démocratique et bien ce sont
pour beaucoup les retraités des
retraités qui arrivent à la retraite
encore en forme et pas des fainéants qui
ne voudraient pas travailler des gens
qui au contraire ce disent que ils
bénéficie de ce moment pour pouvoir
s'engager pour les autres voulez-vous
casser cela aussi il n'en est pas
question pour merci
la parole de Madame Raymonde de penser
merci madame la Présidente alors
effectivement en ce jour ou 3 millions
et demi de Français ont manifesté je
vais vous dire ce qu'ils ont compris ils
ont compris que le report de l'âge légal
d'ouverture des droits à la retraite et
l'accélération de la durée d'assurance
était une réforme injuste brutale
inégalitaire et donc un populaire mais
comme vous n'êtes pas allé à la
manifestation je voudrais vous tirer
quelques pancartes quand même vu lors de
ces manifestations mais trop boulot
tombeau ah tiens à 62 ans 25% des
personnes les plus pauvres appartenant
aux cinq premiers centimes sont déjà
décédés avec votre loi ces 9000 de plus
qui le seront à 64 ans la retraite avant
l'arthrite le relèvement de deux ans de
cet âge lors de la réforme de 2010 c'est
traduit par une hausse de 7 points de
l'invalidité maladie Insee pour financer
les retraites piocher dans les bonnes
poches
c'est ce que nous avons tenté hier de
vous dire
si les femmes étaient payées autant que
les hommes
plus de problème dans les caisses de la
retraite selon les calculs de l'économie
Michael Zemmour pourtant 60% des
économies de la réforme vont être
réalisés sur les femmes allô papy tu
peux garder les enfants ah bah non je
suis au travail en plus de mettre à mal
les liens de solidarité familiale notons
qu'un dirigeant sur deux d'associations
restent bénévoles le recul de l'âge
menace le bénévolat associatif les
hommes comme la planète ont besoin de
repos c'était une autre pancarte car
cette réforme est productiviste
l'intensification du travail abîme le
abîme les corps et aussi vous continuez
cette croissance sur le sol indice du
PIB qui détruit la biodiversité et et
crée le réchauffement des
planètes et enfin le dernier on veut
juste qu'on nous retraite raite
on va passer à monsieur le Président
Guillaume Gontard merci
merci merci madame la Présidente nous
voyons moi sur Dick voir nous voici donc
arrivé au moment tant attendu à
l'article le plus important pour le
quotidien des Français celui sur le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans le noyau de
cette réforme injuste qui fait peser
tous les efforts sur les épaules et
travailleuses et les travailleurs pour
cette première intervention sur cet
article 7 et comme mon amendement sur le
sujet a été déclaré irrecevable la faute
a un vécu encore une fois législatif
totalement inadapté je souhaiterais vous
alerter sur un des nombreuses impacts
négatifs de cette réforme l'impact sur
le fonctionnement de nos associations
le tissu associatif français a été très
affaibli par la suppression des contrats
aidés par la diminution des moyens des
collectivités collectivités locales puis
par la crise sanitaire qui a mis
l'activité de certaines associations à
l'arrêt faisant passer le temps
d'engagement de 24 % 2019 à 20% de
Villepin 2 selon selon France Bénévolat
plus de 16 millions de bénévoles
participent au fonctionnant de notre
million et demi d'associations ces
bénévoles sont la colonne vertébrale du
réseau associatif et l'on sait que près
d'un bénévoles sur trois et justement
retraités le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite présente donc un
risque important de bouleversement du
fonctionnement des associations les
retraités à fortiori les plus jeunes
d'entre eux par leur disponibilité leur
expérience sont des bénévoles
indispensables aux associations
plusieurs associations ont déjà tiré la
sonnette d'alarme l'association Les
Petits Frères des Pauvres a expliqué il
y a quelques semaines que le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans suscité de Vivien quiétude car 14%
des bénévoles réguliers et 15% des
nouveaux bénévoles de leur association
on entre 60 et 65 ans leur engagement
représente plus de 200000 heures de
bénévolats par an quand on sait
l'importance que les associations dans
notre société notamment via leur travail
de maintien du lien social pour pallier
au manque de l'État on peut se demander
pourquoi le gouvernement veut à tout
prix
ignorer les nombreux effets négatifs de
sa réforme donc votre réforme cette
réforme de droite c'est tout simplement
une négociation une négation pardon de
la vie donc soyez responsable retirez ce
texte la parole est à Madame Marie-Noël
lineman
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues
vous le savez pertinemment
en allongeant de deux ans la durée
légale pour partir en retraite vous
assumez que vous allez rendre impossible
l'arrivée à la retraite dans de bonnes
conditions d'un nombre considérable de
nos concitoyens ils n'en peuvent plus la
plupart du temps écoutez-les tous les
témoignages ils n'en peuvent plus être
pas seulement les métiers pénis bien sûr
d'abord eux mais toute une série de
métiers stressants qui pèse lourdement
dans la psychologie de chacun vous savez
pertinemment que vous allez accroître le
volume des seniors qui n'aura ni un
emploi ni une retraite qui seront dans
une précarité insupportable
vous savez pertinemment qu'avec cette
allongement de la durée les pensions
vont diminuer est lourdement et déjà ça
a commencé ça va être encore accéléré
vous savez tout ça alors pourquoi vous
laissez faire pourquoi tant
d'indifférence sur le sort de nos
concitoyens pour vos comptes pour 15 à
18 milliards d'euros en 2030 cet argent
peut trouver autrement
et vous voulez pas voir les vrais
problèmes du monde du travail qui
rempliraient les caisses de retraite
améliorer les salaires changer les
conditions de travail rendre le travail
mieux vécu par nos concitoyens par un
respect dû aux travailleurs il le
demande il l'attendent alors vos
discours sur la valeur travail c'est pas
tripette par rapport à votre absence de
décision en ce sens la réalité monsieur
le ministre c'est que le gouvernement
joue le pourrissement parce que son
idéologie libérale ne veut pas faire
qu'il commence à engager le recul de
cette logique terrible qui fait que le
capital est toujours mieux rémunéré que
le travail ça doit stopper
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente nous arrivons
donc maintenant à la mesure phare de
cette loi et nous y arrivons après six
jours complets de débat pendant lesquels
le gouvernement a rejeté une par une
toutes les propositions de financement
des retraites toutes les propositions
qui éviteraient de faire opposer
l'intégralité de l'effort demandé sur
les millions de travailleurs et surtout
de travailleuses modestes qui dès
septembre devront trimer deux ans de
plus parce que c'est ça votre réforme
c'est pas changer le travail c'est pas
plus de justice c'est faire de la casse
sociale par de la brutalisation
démocratique taxer les dividendes c'est
non faire surcotiser les eaux salaires
c'est non rendre contraignante l'égalité
salariale c'est non augmenter les
salaires c'est encore non mais faire
trimer deux ans de plus les plus
précaires pour rembourser ce que vous
avez donné aux riches ça c'est oui et ça
personne n'en veut dans le pays pas même
vos électeurs à chaque prise de parole
du gouvernement dans cette hémicycle
l'opposition grandit dans le pays elle
ne cesse de s'amplifier aujourd'hui 245
000 personnes à Marseille 120 000 à
Toulouse 100.000 à Lille 100.000 à
Bordeaux 12000 personnes à Annonay
monsieur le ministre 700 000 à Paris il
y avait même des centaines de personnes
mobilisées à Bruxelles à Londres à
Madrid des Françaises et des Français de
l'étranger qui savent très bien dans
leur pays quels sont les conséquences
des pays qui ont décidé de reculer l'âge
de départ à la retraite plus de 3
millions de personnes dans la rue
aujourd'hui malgré les difficultés pour
tant d'entre elles de faire grève pour
dire une chose nous ne vous laisserons
pas nous prendre les deux meilleures
années de nos retraites pour les
remplacer par les deux pires années de
travail et je vais vous dire vous avez
un choix très simple retirez la réforme
maintenant vous aurez la honte passagère
de l'humilité trop tardive
entêtez-vous contre le pays entier et
vous aurez le déshonneur à jamais un
pays brisé et une démocratie au bord de
l'explosion retirez cette réforme
maintenant
merci la parole est à Monsieur Yann
chanterelle
merci merci madame la Présidente nous y
sommes chers collègues nous abordons
donc ce fameux article 7 cœur de
l'injustice et de la brutalité de cette
réforme nous entamons l'étude de cet
article après que des millions de
Françaises et Français viennent de
manifester contre cette réforme afin
d'avoir droit à une retraite descente à
un âge décent pour rappel plus de 75%
des Français et Françaises sont contre
cette réforme ça a été rappelé par
d'autres parlementaires vous avez aussi
au sein de votre propre électorat ou les
Français sont massivement contre cette
réforme et vous le disent constamment
des millions et des millions de Français
françaises manifestent et vous faites ce
soir au moment où on aborde cet article
comme si de rien n'était à l'image du
ministre Dupond-Moretti vous faites un
bras d'honneur au pas au peuple français
qui pourtant pacifiquement
manifeste contre très forte de plus en
plus nombreux imaginez la violence que
vous renvoyez au peuple français par
votre indifférence par rapport à ce
qu'ils expriment constamment dans la rue
imaginez la violence que cela peut avoir
sur des gens qui vont devoir travailler
2 ans de plus alors qu'ils font des
métiers pénibles difficiles ces gens qui
sont les indispensables de notre pays
c'est eux que vous brutalisez vous
pourritaliser le peuple français en
brutalisant les essentiels de ce pays on
ne peut pas gouverner contre le peuple
nous sommes ici pour les représenter
c'est un vrai problème démocratique de
vouloir absolument brutalement imposer
une réforme par des procédures qui
limitent le temps de nos débats qui
aurait mérité justement un débat
beaucoup plus long sur le fond quand on
touche un sujet aussi fondamental qui
touche notre pack de social qui touche
plusieurs générations nous devons
prendre le temps de pouvoir en débattre
c'est pas la voix que vous avez choisi
vous même parlementaire de droite vous
devez vous élever contre ça vous avez
dit vous sortez vous au pouvoir vous
feriez beaucoup plus de concertation bad
diplômes au gouvernement c'est pas ce
qu'ils ont fait donc ce que nous
demandons c'est le retrait de cet
artiste et le retrait de cette réforme
injustée
qu'on connaît
ma présidente monsieur le ministre
collègue une fois de plus les
populations de la dit outre-mer
assisteront un débat qui une fois de
plus leur passera largement au-dessus de
la tête et pourtant le mot
différenciation n'a jamais été autant
utilisé par le gouvernement et pourtant
je n'ai jamais autant entendu dire que
le soleil ne se couche jamais en France
que grâce à la toute première la France
il sait au deuxième rang de la puissance
maritime mondiale que la biodiversité
française grâce à l'Outre-mer relevé de
l'exceptionnel richesse et pourtant
aucune mention dans ce projet de loi pas
un mot même pas un renvoi à
d'éventuelles ordonnances comme on en
attend l'habitude solution souvent de
facilité pour maintenir la poussière
sous le tapis et pourtant dans ces pays
où après les lois de
départementalisation votée en 46 censé
apporter la très chère égalité quel
parcours chaotique jusqu'à nos jours le
résultat aujourd'hui
moi constitution de carrière laborieuses
voire impossible 2% le résultat
aujourd'hui des employeurs qui ont
disparu une pénibilité évidente
difficile à prendre en compte 7%
national 20% dans les outre-mer le
résultat aujourd'hui une retraite
moyenne contenue de toutes ces carences
liées à l'histoire qui plafonnent à 5041
euros quand on sait par exemple que les
produits alimentation sont supérieures
de 38% le résultat aujourd'hui c'est que
pour partir à la retraite à l'âge moyen
dépasse les 65,3 ans alors permettez que
je ris quand on parle de 64 ans moins de
1% d'entre eux partent à 62 ans et donc
augmenter le temps de travail
repousserait ses populations à 67 ans
ouais cette France du soleil qui ne se
couche jamais où est cette France qui
doit beaucoup de domaines à ton corps
l'égalité une fois de plus une fois de
plus les mots ne sont pas alignés aux
annonces et la France continuera de
clamer sa richesse son empreinte dans le
monde et malheureusement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres ça fait quand même du bien de
temps en temps d'entendre la parole de
l'outre-mer ma chère Catherine Concorde
mes chers collègues je vous cache pas ma
perplexité
un quarteron de sénateur
est en train de s'exprimer
potentiellement
je vois que Monsieur Chassin monsieur
Cadix vont dire un petit mot mais
mais où est la droite
nous avons assisté nous avons assisté
depuis six jours à un débat respectueux
riche animée déterminé et il est vrai
que votre silence était particulièrement
étonnant je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues que nous devons la vérité aux
Français il nous regarde au travers des
médias qui nous suivent de manière
attentive chacun l'aura bien compris et
y compris en cette journée très forte de
mobilisation vous avez décidé
effectivement à ce stade de ne pas vous
prononcer j'en suis déçu parce que j'ai
écouté avec attention notre collègue
Bruno Retailleau dans
je suis en général disons mais enfin le
clivage droite-gauche est revenu
oui il est revenu avec cette réforme des
retraites mais n'ayez pas la droite
honteuse
défendez défendez vos opinions défendez
devant les Français ce qui vous semble
bon dans cette réforme un populaire
inutile un juge réactionnel je pense que
vous ne reconnaîtrez que nous avons eu
ce discours que nous avons porté devant
les Français une autre vision de la
société et nous continuerons à la porter
jusque dimanche 12 mars à minuit
messieurs les ministres je vous demande
nous vous demandons d'avoir conscience
qu'il faut maintenant retirer votre
réforme
mais si la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme
Durand
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur sur le rapporteur messieurs
les ministres je souhaite comme les
autres membres de mon groupe m'exprimer
sur cet article 7 d'abord pour me
féliciter qu'au contrairement à ce qui a
été fait à l'Assemblée nationale nous
puissions enfin débattre de cet article
qui constitue le cœur de la réforme
d'ailleurs est-il vraiment opportun de
parler de cœur de cette réforme pour une
mesure aussi unique vous connaissez le
caractère injuste de cette mesure déjà
pointé en son temps par Monsieur Macron
on vit certes relativement longtemps en
France mais nous avons un ratio
d’espérance de vie en bonne santé assez
réduit et cela risque de se réduire
encore on sait aussi que le report de
l'âge légal augmente les dépenses
maladies avec des reports vers le
chômage ou la validité oui les personnes
qui approchons de l'âge de la retraite
multiplieront les arrêts maladie
qu'allez-vous proposer après des jours
de carence supplémentaires pourquoi ne
recherchez-vous pas d'autres solutions
pourquoi j'ouvre les guillemets
écartées d'emblée la recherche d'autres
recettes et notamment la contribution de
l'ensemble des revenus et en particulier
ce issus du capital comme le disait
monsieur du soft quand il était de
gauche je multiplie les questions mais
je sens bien que les réponses se feront
rares tous ceux qui galèreront avec des
alternances de petits boulots et de
chômage pour atteindre l'âge légal
aimerait pourtant bien les entendre ses
réponses pour les seniors qui ne sont ni
en emploi ni en retraite le recul de
l'âge de départ signifie en effet
allongé leur période de précarité nous
avons entendu la présidente de roche
nous demandait de considérer vos
parcours personnels votre expérience
votre enracinement mais précisément dans
vos villes dans vos communes dans vos
préfectures sous-préfectures vous les
avez entendu ce qui disent on ne peut
pas faire les trois huit deux ans de
plus
je ne vois pas pourquoi la droite
sénatoriale vole au secours du
gouvernement qui lui fait des bras
d'honneur à l'Assemblée nationale donc
mépris passage en force bras d'honneur
je crois que c'est le vrai mot
utile pour qualifier ce qui est en train
de se passer
la parole est à Monsieur Daniel broyer
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues oui nous y
voilà la mesure phare ou plutôt la
mesure guillotine aujourd'hui le pays
est bloqué pour lutter contre le report
de l'âge de la retraite syndicat Unis
professeur chemineau éboueur ouvriers
routier aide-soignant ATSEM et même des
noms et des prénoms des femmes et des
hommes toutes et tous réunis dans les
rues pour dire non à cette réforme il le
disent avec détermination et
responsabilité parce qu'elle est injuste
unique parce que vous leur volez deux
années les deux plus belles années de
retraite sans les entendre sans accord
avec aucun syndicat la France est
bloquée et c'est votre responsabilité et
il fallait s'y attendre si le ministre
est formé contre le peuple c'est
toujours dangereux surtout dans cette
période où la démocratie est si menacée
c'est aussi injuste car cette réforme
pénalise les travailleurs les plus
précaires et les plus exposés à la
pénibilité ce qui exerce des métiers
physiquement éprouvants l'ont bien
compris ils ne pourront tenir jusqu'à 64
ans d'ailleurs plus de 20% des ouvriers
sont déjà morts avant l'âge actuel légal
de la retraite quand les milliards de
profits de dividendes volent au-dessus
de leur tête vous choisissez vous de
leur faire payer de deux ans de leur vie
les équilibre de ces comptes de retraite
à l'ouverture de nos débats quand j'ai
évoquais le temps qui reste de Reggiani
vous me répondiez monsieur le ministre
il suffirait de presque rien presque
rien deux ans deux années au travail oui
le travail peut insérer oui le travail
peut être épanouissant mais sachez chers
collègues que la retraite l'est aussi
que la vie sociale la culture l'est
aussi et qu'il y a mille façons de
s'épanouir alors je conclus encore avec
Reggiani deux années des jours des
heures quand j'y pense mon cœur bat si
fort mon pays c'est la vie je l'aime
tant le temps qui reste pour rire pour
courir pleurer parler et voir et croire
laisser ce temps aux Français
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude Tissot
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
certains voudraient nous faire croire
que reporter l'âge légal à 64 ans c'est
juste une solution pour équilibrer le
régime des retraites mais derrière les
chiffres ce sont des vies avec
lesquelles vous jongler monsieur le
ministre et mes chers collègues de
droite je reçois de nombreux témoignages
comme j'imagine beaucoup d'entre nous de
personnes qui me demandent de vous faire
part des conséquences de vos choix sur
leur vie comme moi ces gens-là sont des
classeurs des années 61-71 des gens
d'une génération plutôt rurale qui n'ont
pas fait de grandes études mais qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie dans le
bâtiment les travaux publics
l'hôtellerie la restauration l'industrie
l'hôpital et l'aide à la personne pour
eux je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres 82 kg c'est le poids d'une
bordure de trottoir telle qu'un manipule
tous les jours les ouvriers de travaux
publics dans nos communes dans le froid
la chaleur et les intempéries
81,2 kg c'est le poids moyen d'un homme
adulte que les aides soignants tous les
aides à domicile ont à soulever ou
déplacé 13 tonnes c'est le poids que les
employés d'une entreprise de meubles
demandent département porte chaque jour
en parcourant pour les installer plus de
15 km en équipe est-ce que vous imaginez
chers collègues l'usure que cela
représente pour le corps les
articulations abîmées les douleurs qui
s'installent et ne repartent jamais
alors aujourd'hui qui sont au port de la
retraite ils voient la perspective d'un
repos nécessaire et bien mérité
s'éloigner est un mirage cet article 7
n'est pas une mesure paramétrique
indispensable c'est tout simplement du
vol car ils vole deux années de leur vie
à ces personnes il les dépose des
projets qu'ils avaient pour leur début
de leur retraite à celles et ceux qui
auraient voulu travailler plus longtemps
pour compléter une tension insuffisante
il leur retire le bénéfice de la
surcotte je pense à ce menuisier qui m'a
écrit ce matin ayant commencé à 16 ans
il envisageait quand même de continuer
de travailler jusqu'à 64 ou 65 ans enfin
de pouvoir gagner 250 euros
supplémentaires pour aider ses enfants
après la réforme le gain ne sera plus
que de 40 euros alors ne dites pas que
cette que vous votez cette réforme au
don du travail contre les partisans de
la paresse contrairement à ce que vous
dites vous n'êtes pas du côté du travail
pour lequel vous n'avez aucune
reconnaissance vous êtes encore moins de
celui des travailleurs Baptiste
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre en écoutant nos
débats depuis plusieurs jours maintenant
je ne peux m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour notre jeunesse cette jeunesse dont
on dit qu'elle est l'avenir de notre
pays cette genèse dont on dit qu'elle
doit être bien formée qu'elle doit
poursuivre des études mais dans le même
temps votre effort
incite à tout l'inverse de plus en plus
de jeunes nous disent vouloir rentrer
plus tôt sur le marché du travail pour
justement ne pas travailler jusqu'à 65
66 67 ans
voilà la société que vous êtes en train
de construire voilà l'avenir que vous
êtes en train de dessiner pour la
jeunesse de ce pays à cette jeunesse
déjà frappée durement par la précarité
le chômage l'intérim je lui dis qu'elle
doit se mobiliser massivement comme ce
fut le cas aujourd'hui partout dans le
pays dans les lycées les universités la
jeunesse doit se faire entendre non à
cette réforme non à la retraite à 64 ans
au sein de cette hémicycle mon groupe
votera comme cette article et dans la
rue nous continuerons de soutenir comme
aujourd'hui le droit d'un avenir pour
notre jeunesse
alors monsieur le ministre au risque de
vous surprendre j'ai un point d'accord
avec votre gouvernement une minorité ne
peut pas bloquer le pays mais Monsieur
le Ministre aujourd'hui la minorité elle
n'est pas dans la rue la minorité est
assise sur ses banques sur les bancs des
ministres et c'est vous qui bloquez le
pays
si la parole est à Madame Marie-Claude
varia
merci je suis le ministre chers
collègues alors que le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites conclut que
les dépenses de retraite devrait être
contenu il apparaît important de
rappeler dans quel contexte le
gouvernement avance sa réforme
aujourd'hui depuis le 1er février
la récente loi sur l'assurance chômage
fait que les chômeurs perdent un quart
de leur indemnité et 600 000 ont été
radiés du Pôle Emploi l'inflation sur
les produits alimentaires depuis un an
affichent en février plus 14 et demi
pour cent l'électricité le gaz plus 15 %
les péages autoroutiers plus 4 et demi
et l'essence atteint les deux euros on
est en pleine crise énergétique on a
l’hôpital et l'école à reconstruire un
défi climatique à relever une inflation
à deux chiffres le gouvernement n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux du moment ce
qui se joue avec ce projet de loi c'est
plus qu'un projet de réforme c'est un
projet de société ce sont deux
conceptions de la vie et du travail qui
s'affrontent dans cette hémicycle et
dans la rue les défenseurs du capital de
ce côté de l'hémicycle nom de cesse de
rallonger la durée légale du travail au
nom de la nécessité de produire or
depuis 40 ans nous avons de la robotique
du numérique de l'intelligence
artificielle qui ont participé augmenter
les gains de productivité où sont-ils
passés la vérité c'est que depuis 1982
10% de la valeur ajoutée et passer du
travail au capital et ça représente 250
milliards d'euros c'est donc bien le
partage de la valeur qui est le problème
majeur les cadres de l'intersyndicale le
disent même les dossiers de la Banque de
France montrent qu'entre 1997 et 2019 la
part revenant aux salariés a baissé de
59 à 54% quand la part des actionnaires
a triplé passant de 5 à 16%. si on donne
deux points de plus aux salariés on
trouve là les 12 milliards de plus de
cotisations sociales pour alimenter la
caisse vieillesse les Français merci
désolé sinon
bien merci madame la Présidente tout à
l'heure notre collègue écologiste Daniel
Brouillet a une citation latine j'en
prendrai une autre pour ma part à cet
instant
icrodus x alta vous connaissez sans
doute cette formule tirée d'une fable
des hommes au sens propre on pourrait
traduire par voie siraude c'est ici
qu'il faut sauter au sens figuré prouvez
vos déclarations ici et maintenant pour
ma part il y a deux enseignements forts
de ces six jours de débat le premier
enseignement c'est qu'il n'y a plus une
majorité présidentielle et une majorité
sénatoriale il y a un bloc libéral qui
fait front de manière homogène et solide
pour porter ce projet libéral de réforme
des retraites
le deuxième enseignement fort au terme
d'un amendement et d'un second
amendement vous ouvrez la porte à un
système de retraite par capitalisation
c'est un mauvais coup porté notre
système de protection sociale et je
crois que tout le monde s'en souviendra
alors mes chers collègues de la majorité
vous apprêtez à émettre un vote
historique malheureusement c'est pas
dans le sens du progrès social vous
portez un mauvais coup à notre modèle
social et avec le gouvernement vous
partagerez cette responsabilité ensemble
aux yeux de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyens d'ici au vote nous
continuerons de débattre et d'argumenter
jusqu'à dimanche 12 mars minuit
merci alors mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour la suite
de l'examen de ce texte la séance est
suspendue